I love the smell of THC in the morning
understand me
ain't no morning hitting this [ __ ]
pipe of debt cuz we're about to swing
dick and give up bubblegum it's [ __ ]
Monday you understand me hold them back
no [ __ ] prisoners you know it's a
good day when you wake up and your eyes
are still red from the night before me
and Lee went deep last night I like to
thank [ __ ] Anarchy stars like to thank
[ __ ] cheap with chewed Abba dabbas we
weren't [ __ ] deep I slept like a baby
Jack I remember driving [ __ ] home I
was so [ __ ] don't believe it Joey
enough with the chitty-chat it's Monday
all the September 12th it's a [ __ ]
half brand new set of rules I got some
tremendous we dancing Godzilla left oh
and I got some bread Ian left the
critical mass we [ __ ] burned it to
the death last night if you're wondering
here [ __ ] podcast is up and ready for
you [ __ ] you understand me
I could not find my [ __ ] Pope is dead
but now we're back it's a beautiful day
to be alive the birds are chirping the
Sun ain't out yet but it will be [ __ ]
up doesn't it don't matter the sunlight
from your nutsack should carry over into
a beautiful [ __ ] day you follow me
and that's it I have a couple things
going on I got this I got that I got
some writing I got you jet truck I meet
this guy gotta meet that guy gotta get
my [ __ ] head done I got a thousand
[ __ ] things on the inside there's a
[ __ ] busy day like any other [ __ ]
day but you prioritizing your [ __ ]
mind you break it down you see what's
important what's not important and you
[ __ ] kick some ass but as usual this
is the most important thing of the
[ __ ] day you understand
a little tutu roots never hurt anybody
in fact it gives you a little get get up
and go I'm ready to get up and [ __ ]
go
we got a protein shake on deck little
coconut primal today I like to switch it
up some days I do the Onyx some days I
do the primal
just to keep [ __ ] your body confusing
themselves Oh a lot of people have to
buy a vapor let me [ __ ] jerk off and
blow smoke like that uncle Joey blows it
understand it's gonna be a good day Oh
Monday's are always a good day if you
wake up my point you write your [ __ ]
calls you get a nice breakfast you take
ten minutes for yourself and you focus
on where the [ __ ] you want to go today
you thank God for giving you another day
to get your dick sucked and you move on
you do the best thing you [ __ ] can
and that's it
can I gonna do [ __ ] great all the
time but at least you try it like CW
Punk whatever his [ __ ] name is you
give your own [ __ ] New York try
that's all that matters who gives a [ __ ]
about what they say you know nobody
likes me you think I give a [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] that's the fuel I have in my
nutsack to go out and [ __ ] torment
these [ __ ] because your success
torments people trust me Tony you don't
need to smack them or poke him in the
[ __ ] and I have kicked him in the
stomach just do good and sometimes they
look at you and you crack them for the
[ __ ] day those are the evil
[ __ ] in your life you gotta get
rid of solo like Michael Jackson and
[ __ ] 81 you gotta go solo sometimes
tremendous I'm gonna have a [ __ ] good
day I'm gonna write a little bit this
morning then write my [ __ ] balls for
the week one goal for the week is not to
eat and that's tough because they
haven't gonna [ __ ] it Austin Texas on
Thursday the home Papa dos Chuy's
[ __ ] barbecue the whole [ __ ] me
I'm not waiting on no lunch I'm not one
of those jerk cause I Papa don't wait on
[ __ ] lines like an hour waiting
around for a bomb to [ __ ] jaw this is
fun [ __ ] that I just want my papa those
every day get a nice seafood under Louie
[ __ ] sausage [ __ ] gumbo maybe get
myself a little shrimp and grab the
salad forget about a little lettuce
tomatoes every day you drink that
[ __ ] bottom I like Dumbo water they
can't stop you that's feel for a [ __ ]
nut sack anybody could eat the [ __ ]
the shrimp and the [ __ ] this and the
potatoes in there go get that [ __ ]
that patrina oil seafood mix into your
[ __ ] system they can't stop you
[ __ ] and beside that that's it
and that's that you know you want me to
lie to you I'm not gonna get stung
some people tell ya
pain I've painted my [ __ ] soul you
understand me
that's why smoke [ __ ] reefer with
three hands well I'm not afraid to say
that bathing my solos refuse me every
day to [ __ ] go out there and sling
dick there's no pain no [ __ ]
[ __ ] you think I'm just some fat
[ __ ] you're smoking reefer I'm
dropping I got a Monday morning so
nobody else get dropped behind you so
nobody can get you away with this stupid
[ __ ] IDs say you'll leave that house
ready to stab my mother [ __ ] of the day
I kidnapped that dude I left the house
with bad [ __ ] intentions you don't
leave the house are bad and touch it you
leave the house looking up going you
know what I'm here cause I think my dick
time and eventually by the end of the
block some you'll stumble out and suck
it and that's it and that's that I'm
[ __ ] stoked I make my protein shake
and get my [ __ ] started there ain't
no podcast via them today this morning
ain't nobody cuz the podcast is already
up for you my friend Sabatino was
supposed to call but he didn't [ __ ]
call guarantee [ __ ] passed out or
whatever whatever [ __ ] them
we don't need them we got each other
suckers and that's the word of the day
you got each other look out for your
[ __ ] boom box you see your buddy
there he's having a bad day go from the
[ __ ] 20 make somebody's day today
that's your [ __ ] goal for that they
forget about you [ __ ] you think it's all
okay for you
you see somebody who's down today don't
throw him a quarter throw him a [ __ ]
fence to bat let him know you're a
[ __ ] animal
pay the [ __ ] universe of
you are something good things to happen
did I paid a universal fake from time to
time that's it and that's the [ __ ]
video - I love you [ __ ] with
them they listen from the bottom nothing
so Thursday [ __ ] Austin Texas - shows
Friday to show salmon and the final week
[ __ ] New York City Friday and
Saturday Gotham comedy club shows you'll
be home by 10:30 give me your mama a
little [ __ ] snapping all right have a
good day don't let nobody get in your
way if anything you're gonna get in
somebody's [ __ ] way understand me
stay black [ __ ] them in here uncle Joey
loves you